- Did you play football growing up?
You look like a dude that
played football, just saying.
- Well, thank you very much, Kelly.
- I appreciate you saying that, but no.
I did not.
- Oh!
- I hit a really late growth
spurt later on in high school,
maybe even into college.
And so when I was going into high school,
I played football one year in junior high,
and I wanted to play
football in high school.
And my dad... I was really, really skinny.
And my dad said, absolutely not.
You're not playing
football, they'll kill you.
You'll be broken in half.
Look at these guys,
they're twice your size.
(Kelly laughing)
And so, he was right and
it broke my heart for,
you know, five minutes.
And then I just decided
I needed to do something.
I wasn't going to sit
at home and do nothing.
So, for the first time in my
life picked up a soccer ball.
I had a...
It's interesting.
We had a soccer field,
literally right across
the street from our house.
And so I went over there
and I taught myself how to play soccer
in one summer, poorly.
I made the team, barely,
but that's my soccer story.
- Oh, I love soccer. I
played soccer as well.
That's a fun sport. Now
it sounds like fat camp.
Cause you just have to run a lot
because soccer -
- Just running all over the place.
- It's definitely a cardio sport.
(Justin laughing)
So, I loved it as a kid though.
But have you ever coached
your daughter in any sports?
- Yeah. You know? I did.
And I don't know why.
Here we go about soccer again.
I coached her when she was like, six,
maybe six years old,
five or six years old,
in a soccer league.
And you know, when they're that age,
what they're doing is, they're
just running after the ball.
Wherever the ball goes,
that's where they're running.
There's always like one kid,
maybe two kids on the team,
that are really good and skilled
and know what they're doing
even at that young age.
My daughter was not one of them.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
But she had good team spirit and you know,
they didn't keep score.
Nothing like that.
They're five years old.
These kids are just running
around trying to have fun.
And there's always this one,
at least one parent that just thinks,
they think that their kid is, you know,
a Messi or something, or Brett Favre,
and they're going for the
touchdown in the Super Bowl.
It's unbelievable.
This guy would jump down my throat
and he would run up and
down and ask questions,
why this and why that?
And I would just look at him.
I go, "Dude, you know, we're
not even keeping score here?
Put whatever score you want in your brain,
put it in your brain.
That's what the score is."
(Kelly laughing)
They're winning.
Sure, they're winning, whatever.
We're not keeping score.
But he was into it.
And I thought to myself, that
poor kid, when he goes home,
I mean, his life was probably miserable.
It's probably the greatest
moment of his life
to come play soccer
and not have to worry about
his overbearing father.
- Yeah. Oh my gosh.
It reminds me of that movie.
Was it "Kicking and Screaming"?
The Will Ferrell movie.
Oh my God. I loved that movie.
- It's just like him.
It sounds like him.
- It's awesome. I grew up playing sports.
There were definitely those parents.
And I was like, no one's
going to the Olympics here,
just so you're aware.
- Exactly, let's just have some fun.
- They suck all the fun out of it.